this new book of stories and advice is
called when I was your age so do you are
you the friend of the group that people
like seek advice
from sometimes yes I've had the are you
wise yeah a little bit I mean i' I've
had the blessing of seeing a lot you
know so far cuz starting early you know
what I mean so some people come to me
for things and then you know I chime in
on things that I see that I can't help
so whether they want my advice or not I
end up giving it if it's a natural
reaction or something but yeah yeah I'm
I'm usually just like I've observed so I
can tell you what I've seen I've
observed sound like an owl I like it so
wait so why write a book now uh I just
felt like it was one of those things
that everybody kind of does you know and
I felt like have I achieved enough to
kind of like talk about anything
interesting that would make a book yeah
and then I got to a point where I was
like yeah I think I'm I'm kind of ready
to start like putting stuff out there as
far as like who me really kind of is
that's what I'm saying I think that's
what's interesting you kind of pull the
curtain back behind body always I mean I
imagine I was a cockta waitress in a
comedy club for a couple years and I
before all this and everybody always
expects the comedians to be so funny all
the time and every conversation every
time you run around them and I was like
that has to be exhausting I mean yes and
you don't kind of want to be like
misleading you don't want to do a lot of
comedy and then be like very negative
and boring at the same time yeah but you
know a lot of my presence for people is
very performative because it's always on
a talk show or it's on a actual show or
a movie or something like that so this
was my first time like offering up the
rest of it because I didn't know if it
was you know interesting enough or not
because you know it's just my personal
story you know what I mean because
people don't know that they've known you
for so long you know what I'm saying on
T and like just to be able to like yeah
pull the veil back a bit I think that's
awesome I mean I hope they enjoy it I
hope everybody enjoy it did you like
being that kind of vulnerable do you
enjoy that um it's new and it's it's a
lot to to kind of like balance and you
know tiptoe around like whatever but
that's why I can't write a I don't tipto
yeah yeah I don't I don't tip to well
either I stub my toe a lot yeah um but
it it does feel good to share because
the reaction has been so positive from
people who have read it you know what I
mean so I don't I don't feel like I've
burned any Bridges necessarily by you
know sharing a lot of stories that have
other people involved you know what I
mean because you want people to be able
to tell their own story type thing you
don't want to speak for people but you
know talking from my perspective I was
able to share a lot you know you know
it's my life so it's what I've seen yeah
absolutely you just gave gave me the
title for my future Memoir which is
Burning
[Laughter]
Bridges Burning Bridges just saying
that's right it's a funny Memoir that's
I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
tiptoe thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home w